[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con mi nombre es
ángela gómez y hoy nos acompaña carlos
eduardo pérez es médico infectólogo de
la universidad nacional de colombia y
asesor científico de france 24 las
autoridades sanitarias de la unión
europea y de eeuu agregaron una nueva
advertencia por efectos de vacunación
contra el coronavirus esta vez para el
preparado de astrazéneca y de johnson
johnson la administración de
medicamentos y alimentos fda confirmó
que 100 personas presentaron el síndrome
de guillan barré luego de vacunarse con
el biológico de johnson este es un
trastorno neurológico poco común y
aunque es un número muy bajo en
comparación con las más de 12 8 millones
de dosis surgen preguntas doctor gracias
y que tan probable es que una persona
vacunada luego padezca el guillan barré
que evidencias existen al respecto
recordemos angela que dentro de este
proceso de la vacunación siempre se
lleva un programa de farmacovigilancia
eso es como reaccionamos los seres
humanos ante la vacuna y se observa a
largo plazo se documentó que puede haber
una asociación de 100 casos en más de 12
millones eso hace que el riesgo sea algo
así como punto 00 08 por ciento de
probabilidad de desarrollar este
síndrome
este es un drone me sucede una o dos
semanas después de la vinculación
generalmente es en hombres y es un
cuadro que se resolvió favorablemente en
todos los casos es llamativo sin embargo
es de muy baja frecuencia y si se
relaciona con esta administración por
eso se genera la advertencia
precisamente esta nueva advertencia para
la inoculación de johnson y johnson
llega cuatro días después de que la
agencia europea de medicamentos emitiera
la misma alerta para la vacuna de
astrazéneca que tienen en común esas
dosis
las vacunas de astrazéneca de janssen
son vacunas que se desarrollan con la
plataforma de vectores virales es decir
que se usan adenovirus pero recordemos
que todas estas vacunas están sometidas
a ese estricto protocolo vigilancia hace
un par de meses referenciamos lo que
suceda con los fenómenos de trombosis
inusitada en algún grupo de pacientes
sobre todo en mujeres jóvenes está del
síndrome guillan barré y la asociación
con la de johnson en hombres mayores sin
embargo es tan poca la prevalencia que
no ha limitado el uso de este
medicamento y se siguen usando estas
vacunas en toda la población es
importante mantener los sistemas de
vigilancia en todos los países y se
monitorice en todos los centros adversos
que se puedan relacionar con la bajo
bueno y es que estos no son los únicos
casos en los que se hace presente el
guillan barré que otros medicamentos o
vacunas podrían causar lo cual es la
probabilidad de desarrollar el síndrome
en comparación con una vacuna contra
kobe 19
el síndrome guillan-barré es un síndrome
que siempre ha estado en digamos
relacionado con algunos fenómenos como
enfermedades infecciosas enfermedades
gastrointestinales algunas enfermedades
virales en algún momento se relacionó
con vacunas de influenza pero
generalmente el síndrome guillan-barré
se desencadena por infecciones virales
incluyendo el coronavirus puede
desencadenar una infección de estas en
una enfermedad de secundaria estas las
vacunas y los medicamentos son descansa
mente relacionados aunque hay descritos
casos cuando el síndrome y mucho más son
enfermedades infecciosas las que pueden
disparar este síndrome entonces esto no
es algo exclusivamente de la vacuna es
algo que puede dar en la naturaleza y
también recordar que la propia
enfermedad puede desencadenar también un
síndrome y llamar brevemente en qué
consiste el lilian barry
síndrome guillan-barré es una parálisis
flash ya es decir que el cuerpo pierde
la movilidad en generalmente en forma
ascendente de las piernas se pierde la
fuerza del cuerpo y puede comprometer la
función respiratoria esta es una
parálisis ascendente plácida y en los
casos que se describieron fue reversible
en el 100% de los casos que se
relacionan con la alliance doctor
muchísimas gracias por estar con
nosotros como siempre y el llamado que
repetimos desde france24 es a que lo más
seguro y con su asesoría es vacunarse
sigan con nosotros en france 24 y en
france 24 punto con buen día
[Música]